there was mighty relief this week that
military strikes on Syria for its
reported use of chemical weapons might
yet be avoided this after Russia
proposed putting them under
international control they're destroying
them it's very important to take this
momentum and to use it because what
we're seeing for the first time in a
long time it's the international
community uniting towards an action on
Syria not however said some Emmy peas
until the threat of serious force was
dangled before key players the Russia
would not have moved without the threats
and i SAT through the moved without the
strength but now we have to act and we
have to demand from Syria to follow with
action against promises and words action
which might now allow the outside world
to help millions of victims of more than
two years of violence many of whom have
been forced to flee we are talking about
millions of people don't have enough
support and I think you could do much
more in that field on to Egypt and what
many see as slow progress towards
democracy after the army removed
President Morsi from power and his
Muslim Brotherhood supporters from the
streets several days ago it moved
against Islamic militant strongholds in
Sinai we want this country to succeed we
want to support it to do so but to do so
with the principles and values that we
hold como le faire confiance edifice
militare alarm Egyptian key a pattern a
key for z @ e depois de mubarak but as
they used to say of banks egypt is too
big to fail if it were that this country
did not stabilize it could be the point
of departure for further destabilization
in its neighborhood I think what we can
demand politically is at this stage that
those who are in charge the army and the
government and that they stick to their
own promises that is the return to the
rule of law and to democracy to
elections in resolutions on Egypt MEP is
urged a halt to violence and a speedy
return to democracy including a new
constitution and on Syria condemned the
use of chemical weapons as a war crime
and urged more support for refugees